- I love this.
You're directing again.
- [Actor] Yeah.
- I think that's exciting.
- [Actor] Thank you.
- Not every actor wants
to do all the things
and I think that's
really cool that you love
like, challenging yourself.
So, what's it like directing Bradley?
Like, y'all work together on "West Wing"?
So is that weird?
Cause you were very young on "West Wing".
- [Actor] Yeah, I was 17 when I met him
and he was my age when he met me.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Actor] Which is crazy.
- Do you remind him and
make him feel old for that?
- All the time.
All the time.
No, he's just, I mean, we
have a very close friendship.
We're like very,
we've really close
personal and professional
like partnership.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Actor] But he directed this year too
and oh, we have to explain these photos.
Okay. So he directed this
year and he did episode nine.
He was like, "Can I shadow?"
And I was like,
"I don't know what you're
gonna learn from me,
but okay, Bradley Whitford,
come on in and try to
follow me around for a bit."
And I put him to work.
I put him to work.
I made him play every character
in The "Handmaid's Tale".
I made him learn all the lines.
I made him stand in for me.
And so those pictures,
I don't know if they could show him again,
but those pictures are him.
Bradley Whitford, television
legend, multiple award winner,
been in every movie,
basically working for me.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Actor] Look at how bored he looks.
He's looking at like, Twitter.
- [Kelly] You should
just frame all of these
and send them to him for
like Christmas or so.
- [Actor] I totally should.